[Música]
actualizamos la información económica
nuevamente con jorge hurtado jorge
bienvenido de nuevo comenzamos con el
fondo moral el fondo monetario
internacional que tienen a mira a su
directora así que se trata de cristalina
georgieva que va la silla de los
acusados este lunes la junta ejecutiva
del fondo monetario internacional planea
deliberar sobre el destino de su
directora georgieva es acusada de
presionar al personal para manipular
algunos datos del informe anual doing
bussiness para beneficiar a china cuando
ella era una de las principales
funcionarias del banco mundial
georgieva ha negado las acusaciones en
innumerables ocasiones ayer directores
del fondo monetario internacional se
reunieron con los abogados del bufete
wilmer health que discuten una auditoría
que hizo el bufete para el banco mundial
tras el escándalo en 2018 el informe fue
suspendido el incidente ha llevado a los
críticos a afirmar que china la segunda
economía más grande del mundo tiene
demasiada influencia sobre las
organizaciones financieras
internacionales así es jorge cambiamos
el tema porque hace ya unas pocas horas
se anunciaron los ganadores del premio
nobel de economía hablemos de ellos
galardonados son david carl johan gris y
el invento de vícar por ejemplo fue
premiado por su análisis de los efectos
en el mercado laboral de los salarios
mínimos la inmigración y la educación
mientras que en gris un israelí
estadounidense y el holandés
estadounidense inventé demostraron que
los experimentos naturales son una rica
fuente de conocimiento según la academia
sus investigaciones han mejorado la
capacidad para responder a cuestiones
causales claves el premio fue otorgado a
los economistas por sacar conclusiones
de experimentos inesperados y aplicarlos
al análisis del mercado laboral según la
academia el trabajo de los galardonados
de evolución o la investigación empírica
en las ciencias sociales y mejoró la
capacidad de la comunidad investigadora
para responder a preguntas de gran
importancia para la sociedad este premio
ha sido calificado a veces como el falso
novel porque fue creado por el banco de
eso decía 60 años después de los otros
cinco novelas el de medicina el de
física el de química literatura y el
nobel de la paz un dato curioso raúl es
que de los 86 ganadores de este premio
sólo han figurado dos mujeres en la
historia cambiamos ahora informaciones
que vamos a hablar porque el presidente
de ese país guillermo lasso defiende su
plan de reformas económicas así es y
bueno apeló también al consenso nacional
luego de que la asamblea de su país
devolviera el proyecto de reformas
económicas este proyecto de lazo
contiene tres ejes principales la
simplificación tributaria y reformas en
lo laboral y atracción a la inversión
extranjera según el mandatario no se
aumentará el impuesto al valor agregado
ni el precio del gas de uso doméstico y
va a eliminar gravámenes que afectan a
las clases populares aunque sí va a
aumentar los para quienes ganen más de
dos mil dólares mensuales y nuevas
contribuciones a los estratos más rico
ecuador enfrenta una deuda del 63 por
ciento de su producto interno bruto un
déficit fiscal de 7.000 millones de
dólares así como índices de desempleo y
subempleo del 70% el presidente
ecuatoriano aprovechó la oportunidad el
fin de semana para comentar sobre su
vínculo con 1 fideicomisos en eeuu
revelados por la investigación papeles
de pandora y esto fue lo que dijo
y no tengo ninguna vinculación que
ninguna empresa en ningún paraíso fiscal
en ningún lugar del mundo tal cual como
lo dice la publicación
yo me deshice de muchas compañías
inversiones precisamente para poder
inscribir mi candidatura y ejercer el
cargo de presidente del ecuador jorge
repasemos ahora los indicadores bueno
vamos a comenzar en asia la mayoría de
los mercados de valores del sureste
asiático cerraron al alza por la fuerte
subida del parqué de manila en europa
las bolsas operaron a la baja por los
nervios en torno a la inflación y el
alza de los precios energéticos y para
finalizar la economía por el día de
directo américa la cifra del día la
cifra del día es 1,2 por ciento se fue
el aumento de la inflación en chile en
septiembre el índice de precios al
consumidor acumula un incremento del 4,4
por ciento en 2021 según el instituto
nacional de estadísticas la economía
chilena se contrajo un 5 8% de 2020 y se
perdieron casi 2 millones de empleos
debido a la pandemia pero el banco
central estima un crecimiento del
producto interno bruto para este año de
entre el 10 5% y el 11,5 por ciento y
dejamos la economía jorge para irnos
directo hasta la ciudad de parís o menos